porque con él vamos a hablar del papel
que juega internet y las redes sociales
para la radicalización y captación sobre
todo de jóvenes y adolescentes a la hora
de cometer crímenes y actos ilegales
esto a raíz del más reciente tiroteo en
eeuu el pasado 4 de julio el día de la
independencia que es un saldo de 7
muertos la web entonces realmente puede
o se convirtió en un asunto de seguridad
nacional para washington pues es lo que
vamos a realizar con nuestro primer
invitado al día l fernando coche
analista de inteligencia y riesgos a la
seguridad nacional experto en terrorismo
y de crímenes de odio fernando gracias
por su tiempo por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24
muy buen día lamentablemente pues para
analizar otro crimen de odio digamos que
se cometió en eeuu asediado por estos
tiroteos son masivos y pues la realidad
de la sociedad estadounidense que es
realmente escalofriante en materia de
armas cuál es el papel de internet
fernando las redes sociales en estos
casos
bueno buenas tardes aquí desde españa un
placer estar con vosotros las redes
sociales no son más que el mecanismo de
difusión o de conexión entre las
personas como antes sean otros procesos
de comunicación de masas la prensa o la
radio etcétera centramos el problema de
las redes sociales es que tiene un
alcance mucho mayor una velocidad mucho
mayor y además una accesibilidad total
absoluta incluso para menores de edad y
esto provoca que en un ambiente de
crispación o un ambiente determinado en
este caso de eeuu donde la prueba de las
armas usadas por menores incluso también
es un problema de según cada estado y
según la legislación federal pues lo que
hace es acrecentar los conflictos que
cuando un conflicto social llega a su
máxima expresión pues el el desarrollo
termina en violencia pero la violencia
puede ser controlada o puede ser
reprimida más fácilmente o incluso puede
ser eliminada si se ven los indicadores
de riesgo social a tiempo pero en eeuu
eso no se aplica
la accesibilidad de las armas genera una
capacidad de destrucción que en otros
momentos de otros brotes de violencia en
otros países pues es más dificultoso
genera mucha menos mucho menos daño
porque no sólo utilizar armas de fuego
entonces
la peculiaridad de este tipo de crímenes
que se reiteran y se van a seguir
reiterando en eeuu demuestra dos cosas
uno la fractura social gente que se
siente absolutamente
aislada no comprendida con motivos o sin
ellos no necesariamente con problemas
psicológicos es un error los problemas
psicológicos y psiquiátricos de las
personas no afectan la violencia de
manera significativa es un índice muy
bajo de personas con trastornos mentales
que generen violencia normalmente son
ser violencia contra ellos mismos pero
si una fractura social de gente que no
se siente en algún motivo arraigada en
la sociedad en la costumbre o en su
comunidad y al tener acceso a las armas
y a la difusión de internet se dan dos
mezclas muy importantes la violencia
ejecutada de manera
rápida con las armas de manera muy
agresiva
alta letalidad y por otro lado las redes
sociales lo que provoca ese pequeño afán
de protagonismo de que al menos alguien
les escuche y en la red social les
facilita el canal de comunicación por
tanto será una mezcla absolutamente
explosiva que ya en otros países está
empezando a determinar lo adelantó con
las armas pero sí con crímenes de odio o
incitación a la violencia a ciertos
grupos étnicos religiosos etcétera sí
pero fernando hablemos entonces de las
regulaciones digamos en el caso de eeuu
que puedan tener o que se están llevando
a cabo para evitar que este internet sea
un medio masivo digamos de difusión de
estos mensajes de odios donde además
también estos son perpetradores de
crímenes en muchos casos tienen
seguidores incluso que los alientan y
los apoyan digamos a cometer estos
crímenes de odio crímenes contra la
sociedad contra inocentes civiles
claro es que ahí está el problema
en la lucha entre lo que es la seguridad
seguridad total no existe y los derechos
fundamentales a la difusión de las
opiniones políticas o ideológicas y cuál
es el límite por ejemplo en españa todo
lo que afecta al artículo 18 de la
construcción es decir el derecho a la
intimidad a las comunicaciones a la
información a la capacidad de expresión
de tus ideales no de forma violenta pues
está contemplado como un derecho
constitucional e insalvable o sea no se
puede atacar pero en eeuu el problema
reside en que lo único que hay es una
fractura como hemos dicho ante una
altura social que no puede no permite la
represión el control de los medios de
comunicación precisamente por la ley de
la quinta enmienda aquella que favorece
en la posibilidad que las personas
expresen incluso de manera con lenguaje
agresivo sus opiniones políticas o
superiores religiosas y eso está
contemplado en la posición de eeuu
y no puede eliminarse por tanto si
queremos controlar lo deberíamos
controlar internet que es muy difícil
monitorizar internet que es muy difícil
y es en una democracia consolidada choca
afrontar los hechos fundamentales la
única legislación lógica reglamentación
que se puede hacer es la de reforzar la
eliminación o el control de las cuentas
de los mensajes que sean agresivos o que
inciten al odio directo pero claro hay
tal volumen de tráfico en internet hay
tal velocidad del gráfico en internet en
las redes sociales eso es prácticamente
imposible no se puede hacer o sea
digamos que en el caso de eeuu la única
forma de poder tener más control sería
con una modificación constitucional
así es sólo económica y constitucional
que no se va a dar porque son hay gente
que no está dispuesta a modificarla tras
las enmiendas de los padres fundadores y
es la única forma pero claro eso
significaría que también perdería parte
de la identidad propia de eeuu de la
libertad de expresión de la capacidad e
incluso de por ejemplo en otros países
ocurre que su delito en estos ríos no
quemar la bandera incluso declararse
contra el gobierno que considera el
nuevo legítimo y cierto grado de
independencia política
en este caso de esa reforma es la única
forma de poder controlar al menos los
derechos de la información que sea de
origen violento pero en todos los países
que se ha intentado regular este tipo de
situaciones se ha enfrentado con que
claro no hay un límite claro explícito
de que es ir contra
el gobierno de manera legítima por
ejemplo y que es incitar al odio oa la
violencia y luego es comprobado por
ejemplo con el asalto al capitolio claro
con las soflamas del de los llamados
preparación istas los nuevos nuevos
miembros del ala más conservadora sino
al 3% que llevan entre ellos o las
milicias por tanto va a ser muy
complicado y poner sus de meter a redes
sociales que ya es técnicamente algo
difícil de controlar pues no se puede
hacer de hecho es una es un camino sin
salida y no creo la difusión fácil